you know it could be a while before we
learn the cause of a deadly prank plane
crash in Louisiana the plane went down
about a minute after takeoff in
Lafayette on Saturday now the aircraft
appears to have clipped power lines and
some trees before hurtling to the ground
five of the six people on board the
plane were killed there was one man who
survived and is in critical condition
this morning mo la lengua is here with
us at the table what is the focus of the
investigation now well exactly what
happened there is some video that will
help in their investigation but you know
the question right now that
investigators are really looking into is
why the plane drifted so low and
ultimately crashed and while officials
do have those two videos that will help
in their investigation they say that it
could take more than a year to
ultimately determine the cause these
cell phone videos taken just moments
after the crash show the wreckage fully
engulfed in flames
there is no distress call that we were
aware of officials also know if no black
box aboard the piper twin-engine prop
plane which was almost completely
destroyed the wreckage is in pretty
tough shape between impact damage and
fire damage so there's there's not a lot
to work with our people are experts
though and they will we'll find it as
much as they can the five killed were
headed from Lafayette to Atlanta to
watch LSU in the Peach Bowl the Saints
brought in six wide receivers among them
Carly McCord
a sports reporter and the
daughter-in-law of LSU's offensive
coordinator Steve Ensminger who found
out about the crash just before the game
his son mccords husband posted a tribute
on Instagram saying I'll never be the
same without you Carly
you are and will forever be my world
after the game LSU quarterback Joe
borough was told about his coach's loss
on live TV did you not know I didn't
know that I didn't know you didn't know
yeah we don't want three people on the
ground were injured in the crash two
suffering smoke inhalation the third
Danielle Britt was in her car and left
with burns on about 30% of her body it
was a tragedy felt by the entire city
says Lafayette mayor president-elect
Josh Guillory I know this community
we work together we play together we
have fun together we hurt together and
we will heal together obviously
devastating for the city devastating for
the families just uh just a devastating
wreck you know my heart hurts for the
people I'm from that area when the plane
went down it was about seven minutes
from my parents house so we went to the
scene right away and there you know the
one survivor who walked away it's an
incredible story Wade Burgess is his
name he was pulled out of the pain
literally on fire by one of the buys to
take him to a local hospital and there
was also a lady who was in a car in the
parking lot of the post office that the
plane hit she survived childhood cancer
and is now fighting for her life but she
is expected to recover 30% of her body
there was was was covered in wounds
there and Wade who you mentioned yeah
hospitalized critical condition still
and a 15 year old boy who died he was
going to turn 16 the next day family
everybody involved in the crash
absolutely
you